- On this episode I give
a Jets, Colts prediction,
we talk sandwiches
and when was I wrong last?
♫ Hey
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ Hey, and I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
(bass synthesizer)
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 141
of the the #AskGaryVee Show.
Super pumped, uh, this is a
Friday, it's really Thursday
as you can tell I tape
the night before and
that's what was Thursday's episode
and I'm leaving for a wedding on Friday.
But Friday's episode,
which is the official Jets
prediction show so I'm excited
to give you my two cents on that.
I'll save that for the end of the show.
I'm gonna be like a TV show
where you save the good stuff
for the end to make them
watch all the way through
for the ratings.
I'm in a good mood and Stunwin
let's get into the show.
He expected me to do somethin'
- [Steve] His show,
- did you see that I got
- [Steve] the show.
that was good right?
I killed him on that,
- [Steve] Show.
- I got you on that one
'cause you were tryin'
to figure out when my
cadence was I went in for it.
- [Steve] You're a bad person.
- Bad, bad, I'm a bad.
(people laughing)
I'm a bad man (laughs).
- [DRock] Bad man.
- [Voiceover] David asks,
"What would you do
"if you were the new CEO of Twitter?
"How would you turn that ship around?"
- David I would do a couple things.
One I would recognize that
the data that we're collecting
on a daily basis is
disproportionately valuable
to a lot of real time marketers
and real time data analysts.
You saw Bloomberg Twitter
JV come across the headlines
for me I haven't read it
yet but that's exactly
where I'd go putting my
money where my mouth is.
I invested in the company
called Data Miner years ago
that I felt Twitter would or should buy
or become a big company
on the backbone of that.
I would also recognize that normal people
don't understand Twitter.
Twitter as a product is
not as easy to understand
as Facebook and Instagram
and that is a friction point.
When you look at the data
that shows how many people
have signed up for Twitter
but then have not been active
that's a vulnerability.
So I would hire the
single best product guy
that I could, or gal,
and so product person
would be very, very, very high on my list.
I would not guess, I would
poach with all my ability
with disproportional
economics and give them
as much stock as I had to from
a Facebook or an Instagram
or things of that nature.
I would probably make
a very aggressive plan.
I would change the logo of the bird.
I would probably change it to a cat and
have the cat eat the
bird as a symbolic notion
to it's a totally different company.
So I think you'd need a branding play
that would change the optics.
So I would change the
logo from a bird to a cat.
I would tell Wall Street
that they should start
selling my stock now
because I'm not gonna be a CEO
that's gonna confine itself
to making numbers on an
every 90 day basis and
that I have empathy for that's
how they have their business
and I probably only would
have gotten the job as CEO
of Twitter if I communicated
that to the board
and the biggest stockholders
who then clearly, weirdly
allowed me to go become the
CEO 'cause they wouldn't care
about their stock price
over a 24 month period.
'Cause it would go way, way
down because my behavior's
more predicated on business building
not so much Wall Street appeasing.
So there's a lot of
things that I would do.
I would also recognize that Twitter is one
of the true social networks.
That the value in listening
is very big on Twitter.
Whereas Instagram, Pinterest, Facebook,
Tumblr they are, Snapchat,
it's pushing content out.
It's more of a content
management system, a CMS,
where Twitter has a lotta
listening capabilities.
It is where you have a conversation.
It is the place you go for
now when something happens
in the world 'cause people wanna talk.
Starting to move a
little bit in Instagram,
there's some of that behavior.
But those are some of the
top line things I would do.
- [Voiceover] Kamil asks,
"How would you raise money
"for a college business club?
"We'd love to bring more members
"to a New York City competition."
- Kamil I think raising
money is all about asking.
I would, let's pretend
Steve and I were partners.
Steve we need to raise more money.
- Okay.
- Who do you know?
Do you have a rich uncle?
- Yeah actually I do.
- (laughs) Weird, let's call him.
And so that's basically, that was funny,
that was basically what we would do.
You'd have to, what I think you need to do
is you need to map the 1,000
people that you could ask.
All the way from and you
know I said when uncle
to hey, that kid in our school looks
like he dresses extremely
well, he might have some money.
Like, I'm not kidding.
Raising money is called asking for money
so you have to get into the
behavior of asking for money.
So you map on piece a paper, hand written,
you know collect the data, who
are you gonna ask for money?
You start with your mother and the people
that you're closest to or for
me one of the biggest things
I do in business is I start
with, you know I could think
of three or four executives who I know
that I could ask anything for
'cause I brought them so much value.
Remember why I like jab so much?
When you really need
it, it's nice to be like
hey Rick, I need a million bucks.
And when Rick knows that
I've disproportionately
put 8 million in his
pocket, he still may say no
and remember if you ever read
the article I'm still okay
with that but it's nice
to know that Rick would be
at the top of the list
along with Uncle Milford.
- [Steve] Rich Uncle Milford.
- Rich Uncle Mil, you
know what a rich uncle...
you know what, I want it.
(Steve laughs and claps)
Andrew, Andrew.
- [Andrew] No I, I, I....
- Get in here, next question.
- [Voiceover] Alright, video question
from someone I think you know.
- Hey, VaynerMedia employee.
- [ Voiceover] We're doin',
- [Gary] Oh, we got it?
- wait here's Andrew
Get in here Andrew.
- What's up?
- The Vayner Nation's very
excited about this moment.
Don't worry I'm not testing
you're Jet's fandom.
I need you to make a new
shirt for our collection.
I want it for next week's episode.
A rich Uncle Milford.
- Rich Uncle Milford, alright.
- We created a fake character here.
His name is rich Uncle Milford.
- [Steve] He's gotta be
wearing a sweater vest.
- It's gotta say rich Uncle,
don't give him creative,
rich Uncle Milford and then just,
and you're good at drawing,
draw rich Uncle Milford.
Want some bucks.
- [Andrew] Should we use
- He's got a nice little
chest.
- [Andrew] Stunwin's uh--
- Alright get outta here.
- Alright thanks.
- [Steve] Sweater vest think about it.
- Make him look like an
old version of Stunwin.
- [Andrew] Uh, that's what I was thinkin'.
- [Steve] Alright on to the next.
- Let's do this.
(people laughing)
You're gonna wear it too.
- Hey Gary, the sandwich enthusiast here.
- Sale.
- You talk a lot about
how video is the future
of social media.
How do you decide which video content goes
on which video platform?
And secondly, if the New
York Jets were a sandwich
what type of sandwich would they be?
- Ah, Jo's.
You keep answering questions,
I'll keep making sandwiches.
- That's my man Shawn.
(video keeps playing quietly)
Oh, you always get caught with that.
That is a wonderful VaynerMedia
employee here, Shawn.
Uh, ba, bum, bum, ba.
You know I reverse engineer audiences.
So Facebook's incredible
and I've a complete hard on
for Facebook because
if I wanna make a video
for a 60 to 80 year old female, I know
what kind of content goes there versus
a 30 to 35 year old male whose a Jets fan,
who lives in New Jersey.
I can curse there, I can be Jersey right?
Like if I'm doing a video
for 52 to 58 year old females
who are fans of Joel Olsteen
and live in South Carolina
it might not be the right
video to be like f- you.
That,that, that might not work right?
So one I love Facebook
for that 'cause I feel
that gives me the whole breadth.
Instagram skews 40 and under,
Snapchat I get real silly,
I can be really ridiculous,
the rainbows, you know and so it's
about reverse engineering the audience.
Who's gonna consume it,
where is it gonna be?
Twitter because I think
it's more news oriented,
more things of that
nature so maybe a video
where I'm talking about
breaking news or my thought.
Like my thoughts on
Snapchat or the other day.
That would've been a video I
would have definitely debated
to go into Twitter because
so many people newsworld
are hard core on Twitter
so if they saw that,
they retweet it, I get distribution
so it's reverse engineering,
reverse engineering Shawn.
If the Jets were a sandwich
they'd be a Sloppy Jo.
(people laughing)
- [Voiceover] Excellent.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] Kyle asks,
"When was the last time
"you were wrong and how did you handle it?"
- Kyle this is a great
question damn it Stunwin.
I'm wrong a lot.
I don't talk about being wrong a lot
because here's the secret weapon.
Guys it's taken 141 episodes
to get to the secret weapon.
Stunwin the secret weapon
to why I am the way I am.
Staphon I need massive
graphics right now.
Give me some like rockets coming up here.
Secret weapon (whistles)
(rocket engines roaring)
I am wrong so much it's kind of scary.
But for some unknown reason,
I haven't fully quantified
this, I'm not capable
of giving it much thought
and actually spend zero
time post gaming it.
I don't microanalyze for hours, days,
weeks, months, years
and this is for some of
you out there, lives.
For your whole life, you're microanalyzing
why you made that mistake.
You know here's a good mistake.
I passed on Uber's angel round
and left 200 million dollars
cold hard cash out of my pocket in a world
where my game is being a business man.
I would argue that my biggest mistake
is disproportionately bigger
than any of my victories.
I just don't you know, I'm
just not crippled by it.
I have friends who passed on things
and they just can't ever
get over it, get over it.
So, what was my last mistake?
I probably made one in my last meeting.
I'm probably making one right now.
I make tons of wrong hires,
I say things that don't sell
in a meeting, I make bad investments,
I make wrong strategies.
I started four massive initiatives
for VaynerMedia this year,
two crush, two are failing.
Like, I mean, I you know,
I make mistakes all day.
I just don't respect my mistakes.
- [Voiceover] Best wine club asks,
"How do you define value
wine and what are a couple
"of your favorites?"
- The way I define value
wine is by tasting it.
I have a great palate, a deeply
knowledgeable wine palate
at this point I like to say so myself.
But this answer's for
anybody who's into wine.
When I taste something that I know tastes
a hell of a lot better
than what I paid for it,
it's obvious to me, it's very obvious.
The Chocolate Box that we're
selling today on Wine Library,
big push, actually here comes right hook.
Put the big label here
and link it up Staphon
in Facebook and YouTube,
guys you should buy
this wine it's $13.88, it
tastes like it's a $35 wine,
the end, that's value.
So to me when I taste, you
know it's like that senator
who said when they were
defining pornography
on the internet on Capitol Hill
and he was like I don't know
how to define it but when I see it I know
what pornography is.
I can't fully define it for
you but the second I taste it,
because I have context, that
scale, I know what it is.
And so to me the thing that
you should be thinking about
is tasting wines, if you
like them and you feel good
about what you paid for it.
I'll give you a couple fun facts.
So I gave you the Chocolate Box,
I would say Portugal's a great region
to try a lot of value for sure.
The Italian reds, there's a
ton of value in non chianti's,
non Tuscany, non Piedmont,
there's a lot of other stuff.
But just try a lot of wines
in the $8 to $15 range.
It's an incredible sweet
spot, there's a ton of wine.
And Stunwin why don't we take this answer
and this question and write an article
on GaryVaynerchuk.com of
my eight, uh let's do this,
my 11 favorite wines at $11 and under.
And then we'll link it to this
and we'll catch up with it.
That was actually fun, a little
more wine once in awhile.
That's it?
Official prediction time guys.
I predicted the Jets to be
10 and six in last episode.
I had the Colts as one
of the Jets' losses.
But I'm affected by last week,
we got to see everybody play
in real time and I think the
Indianapolis Colts are broken
in the trenches on the
offense and defensive line
which is like the core of your, you know
Mike the trainer taught me
my core was very important.
That to me is the core of a
football team, the trenches.
I think they're broken
and I think the Jets ride
the momentum of last
week's win in second half
and stun the Indianapolis
Colts on Monday night football
which I will be there.
I'm gonna make a sign.
Marshall and then the n's
gonna be a d, and Fitzpatrick.
So I'm gonna try to get on Tv, look for me
and as a matter of fact,
DRock can somebody make
that sign for me, I can't make signs.
Anyway, but real quick the official score
of the game is I think the Jets score,
I think the Jets score in this game.
I'm goin' 26, 21 New York Jets.
It's not over DRock.
I'm doin' the whole, you
know, statement of the day
and then I, I gotta you know (laughs).
I don't know if you missed the cadence
of how we do it here.
Statement of the day.
What is your lock of the week?
I like the football stuff and
then please again feedback
on today's show.
What do you think about
the questions, answers?
Give me some feedback on the wine stuff.
Is that fun to interject?
Should we go in other directions?
Trying to get a little more
detailed in some stuff as well.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop dance music)